c'est une histoire comme il en arrive
parfois en france celle d'une chaîne de
solidarité pour venir en aide à un jeune
migrant guinéens sur le point d'être
expulsé c'est à besançon que la
solidarité s'est déployée face à la
situation du jeune lady fodé traoré
apprenti boulanger qui avait réussi à
s'intégrer et qui aujourd'hui menacée
d'expulsion
une situation incompréhensible pour le
dirigeant de la boulangerie stéphane
watelet qui a décidé d'entamer une grève
de la faim pour venir en aide à son
salarié
il n'est pas le seul à tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé face à cette situation injuste
la maire europe ecologie les verts de
besançon anne vignot a elle aussi
demandé au ministre de l'intérieur de
faire quelque chose avec les élus de la
majorité municipale de besançon nous
demandons au ministre monsieur darmanin
que monsieur l'oeil fodé traoré ne
soient pas expulsés et soit régularisée
ce soir stéphane watelet est avec nous
pour nous faire passer son message
merci stéphane d'être là merci merci à
vous tous pas c'est nous qui vous
remercions alors vous allez voir ce
témoignage de stéphane il est fou de son
histoire et regardez ce que m'a amené
stéphane un petit pas moins aux roms et
sirops d'agrumes merci merci beaucoup
pour votre attention alors stephan laï
c'est un jeune homme de 18 ans oui un
très long parcours avant d'arriver en
france il est parti de guinée il passe
par le mali la libye traverse la
méditerranée pour rejoindre l'italie il
arrive enfin en france etc il ya plus
d'un an septembre 2019 que vous avez
pris là est en contrat d'apprentissage
de deux ans vous aviez fait un appel
d'offres
oui c'est vrai ça voilà et vous vous
avez un manque de candidats et lui il a
tout de suite été volontaires pour
revenir vous aider dans votre
boulangerie si l'on en fait j'avais déjà
fait une un article dans l'est
républicain le du rhône alain de
l'assurance il est en fait pour dire
qu'on trouvait ni ouvriers ni apprentis
et en fait ben en fait par ce biais là
en fait sa tutrice a vu le journal est
en fête
enfin on a eu beaucoup beaucoup de
migrants mais que des migrants en fait
est là et c'est
est arrivé avec son sa petite gueule
d'ongles et en fait il a eu un geste
pour m'aider en fait je devais donner
accès à ces mon bureau et je devais
donner quelques rythmes a besoin d'eux
dans ma collaboratrice est en fait il a
pris il a pris la chose et ils
l'emmenaient chili bon ben c'est bon hop
on signe demain c'est ça vous avez vu
tout de suite qu'il était volontaire
qu'il avait un potentiel exactement
alors vous saviez qu'il n'avait pas de
pas qui n'avait pas de famille en fait
c'était un jeune guinéen carte
d'identité un passeport parle c'est ça
c'est ça alors on le sait c'est un
métier très exigeant un boulanger c'est
très difficile pour ces 6 jours sur 7 6
à 3 heures du matin oui est-ce qu'il
était là avec vous tous les matins 3
heures du matin il a permis aux acteurs
jamais donc c'était une fierté pour vous
de paris vous aviez fait parce que vous
aviez fait un pari et vous a pas déçus
tout à fait je vous serais extrêmement
ému stéphane si anormal en vite donc il
était là tous les matins troisième il
est un travail exceptionnel est devenu 8
c'est pas son nom de la boulangerie bas
il n'a pas fait d'études avant vous
savez pétrir une patte c'est vivant
surtout chez moi parce qu'on
travaillerait mois l'ancien on travaille
le on travaille beaucoup d'eau et en
fait c'est c'est dans la main que vous
recommande que vous recommandez vous
connaissez votre pâte en fait s'il est
bien scellé sur pétrissent il est passé
pétri est en fait le gamin mais il a
tout de suite découvert la chose
donc voila vous verrez tout appris oui
mon ouvrier aussi enfin voila c'est chez
nous c'est la famille en fait on est une
toute petite entreprise et on prend tous
et le soin des uns les autres
leur travail oui oui je pense 13 euros
vous êtes vous savez c'est tellement dur
que si vous en avez marre ou n'est plus
quoi il a il aimer ce métier de la
boulangerie l'assurent ils ont misé
l'aiment encore la main qu il faut pas
parler ou pas en faire son métier
bien sûr d'accord alors il avait signé
la plomberie oui et trouvez pas de deux
mètres raconte serge s'est très vite
adapté
vous dites de l'est c'est un bon gamin
qui veut travailler c'est ça et en fait
on on détruit le futur d'un à trois
heures du matin c'est pas évident mais
je peux vous dire que même à 50 en mai
mais en fait on dit oui voilà on a
détruit on ferme on veut détruire son
futur
alors qui c'est un gamin qui je vais
vous dire il prend pas la place d'un
autre
puisqu'on n'a pas d'autres donc moi que
mes la coopération la comparaison en
fait des italiens qui sont venus de
guerre et les espagnols des portugais
qui sont venus parce qu'il y avait la
misère et et autre chose et ils ont
construit la france aussi alors pourquoi
ces gamins-là qui veulent travailler qui
veulent être présents qui consomme pas
ce que c'est les grands consommateurs
bien sûr donc mais laissons le laisser
les nous dans nos fournis dans les
ateliers dans tout un pan dans le
confinement et travailler avec vous bien
sûr il a pas eu peur et venez bien sûr
tous les jours on ça va être un bon
boulanger pour plus tard bien sûr il va
faire ça y va où va sa boulangerie après
il a il a 18 ans on est gamin encore à
18 ans mais moi qui lui offre un cursus
en fait chez moi c'est à dire que nous
on a de la chance dans la filière
boulangrie c'est qu'on a le crp qui est
donc diplômant on a une année
supplémentaire qui s'appelle la mention
complémentaire et après le bp et tout ça
en fait ces diplômes ans donc en fait on
peut construire une carrière avec des
gars pas mal d'études et moi je lui
proposais que je propose à l'état en
fait de le prendre de le former et avec
tous ces diplômés il peut pas il peut
partir partout dans le monde
alors aujourd'hui il ay est menacé de
quitter le territoire oui quand ils
arrivent en france il est considéré
comme mineur isolé le problème c'est que
là il ya aujourd'hui 18 ans il ne l'est
plus mineures donc il est donc visés par
une obligation quitter le territoire et
ce à une embolie
c'est une obligation mais il ya un terme
aussi que je vais revenir dessus parce
que beaucoup beaucoup de journalistes et
de en fait on
alors je vais essayer de retrouver le
terme voilà c'est un éloignement
ce n'est pas expulsion surtout parce que
on expulse quelqu'un de dangereux dans
la loi d'accord c'est un éloignement des
lycéens éloignement parce que c'est un
bon gamin une cfa il a jamais fait de
problèmes je lui avait dit tu as en
amont à son arrivée dans mon entreprise
ni mon gamin tu migrants t'es pas
quelqu'un n'est pas quelqu'un dont on va
dire normal en fait dans la société et
il va falloir que tu fasses attention
donc tu ne fais pas l'idiot thomis et ça
il faut qu'il fallait qu'il soit encore
plus irréprochables que les autres c'est
ce que je lui dis dix fois cent et il
l'a été
il a été moyen jamais vous a jamais
déçus permet alors il est donc là en ce
moment il est quoi il est entre deux
eaux en fait on attend on attend le
jugement
je regarde mes fiches parce que je suis
pas un grand orateur comme vous on
attend le jugement de
nancy il me semble le 26 janvier alors
il travaillait comme en ce moment
non non il peut pas travailler que vous
dès maintenant parce que l'état l'état
en fait nous demande de prendre des
migrants pour les former voilà très bien
mais l'état nous le reprend pourquoi moi
parce qu'il a 18 ans c'est ça parce
qu'il n'a pas de papiers parce que ça
laisse quand il était mineur et pour y
travailler
pourquoi il les laisse à la base alors
mais c'est la grande question les formes
et juan parallèle en fait le fait ou
bien on les laisse dans le bateau
gonflable on regarde ailleurs
il coule mais on a regardé ailleurs ou
bien on leur ouvre les portes parce
qu'on leur ouvre les portes à 16 ans ils
ont un portable
ils ont un appartement ils ont les
vêtements ils ont des vacances donc tout
cet argent que l'état français met
dedans auxquels on fait killing doyer
avec leur départ
alors qu'avec une politique beaucoup
plus longues de visibilité le sait le
genre de personne et bien en fait on
arrive à modeler les personnes à leur
donner du travail dans des emplois qui
s'ils n'ont pas bien sûr de l'apprenti
ou d'ouvriers et c'est alors vous face à
cette situation
vous avez décidé d'entamer une grève de
la faim oui pour garder votre apprenti
vous ne mangez plus depuis dimanche à
minuit oui ça va quand samedi minuit
samedi minutes mais vous vous sentez
super bien qu avec vous non vraiment
vous sortez vos biens non mes premiers
deuxième jour et à fond parce qu on est
excité puis en plus grâce aux réseaux
sociaux enfin que j'ai pas si vous avez
vu les lits chauds sur ses possibilités
marquer mais on est à 140 alors parce
qu'ici on chez moi où on à 404 signature
sur la semaine et on à la pétition
lancée il ya sept jours on a cent
quarante deux mille six cents sur chaque
point oui quand vous est venue cette
idée de faire une grève de la faim
je vais vous poser une question oui si
je ne l'avais pas fait grève de la faim
est ce que je serai là non c'est vrai
parce qu'on n'aurait pas été au courant
moi je sida non violent et je me suis
dit ma
tu vas violente et ton corps et ton
esprit on va on va dire que c'est
quelque chose de sérieux et on est les
rédactions de presse vont venir te voir
hier entre hier et aujourd'hui j'ai eu à
peu près 40 interviews tous les milieux
ont repris les médias de presse écrite
dont on pourrait bien sûr sur les
réseaux sociaux ça a été c'est un énorme
buzz c'est une avalanche et bien sûr moi
que je enfin je suis pas je suis pas je
suis pas fait pour ça moi je suis un
simple boulanger moi je suis dans mon
fournil pratiquement 15 heures par jour
voire plus je n'appartiens pas à votre
j'appartiens pas aux orateurs
j appartiens pas moins chiant manuel fut
un pur manuel c'est pas mais enfin je
lèverai pas combattre c'est pas ma vie
devant le combat pour mon entreprise
depuis 24 ans mais que je ne lis jamais
pensé combattre pour quelqu'un en fait
ce n'est ce gamin est arrivé ce gamin
valeur de karting à main mais oui mais
vous avez dès janvier j'avais des
enfants ses fins je suis en train
d'adopter d'accord et j'ai ça vous
l'avez considère un peu comme un met
office tout tout tout mes employés sont
font partie de la famille il suffit de
regarder regarder son sourire c'est vrai
qu'il est là aujourd'hui
s'il devait repartir seriez dans quel
état je le présume que je vis ici de
deux de faire la grève de la faim
jusqu'au 26 et je travaille toujours
d'accord qui figurent aux folies vous
pouvez pas l'adopter je dis une bêtise
peut être assez non mais on ya pensé à
l'adopter on ya pensé j'ai encore comme
je suis déjà en train de vie ma fille et
je ne peux pas être partout mais oui
c'est ça pète une idée on m'a lancé des
raids sur les réseaux sociaux bien sûr
vous seriez prêt à l'adopter
bon pourquoi pas il a envie lui un peu
après et vous considère et l'ice est un
grand taiseux ylang autant un grand
sourire qu'ils étaient eux mêmes donc
ils super discret que jamais on l'entend
au fournil est-ce qu'il parle français
oui comment encore mieux que moi c'est
assez important pour l'intégration
famille
une intégration il était bien intégrée
des qualités d'arrivée alors aujourd'hui
on va attendre la saison vous allez
faire la grève de la faim jusqu'au 26
janvier
alors je vais essayer vous avez essayé
mais ça se passe plutôt des relations
parce que c'est vrai que j'ai déjà fait
petit problème de santé oui vous avez
vous avez pas peur pour votre santé vous
fait suivre
willimon infirmière qui vient tous les
trois jours mais comment si si je le
fais pas tu sais qu'il le fait on va le
regarder partir comme tous les autres
moyens dossier puis un dossier de 2-2
autres alors il y en a bien plus un mais
le nous autres apprentis en fait
yen inquiète dans un garage le le
garagiste il pleurait quand il m'a
téléphoné et pas de problème c'est être
pas de problème on comprend le monsieur
à 50 ans ou à peu près il est tellement
attaché à ce gamin qui pleurer en me
disant la préfecture ne veut rien faire
le maire ne veut rien faire vous avez eu
le courage c'est pas du courage de faire
une grève de la faim pour faire bouger
les choses pour faire bullygeois j'ai un
certain mental et voilà un objet mais
c'est une évidence pour moi
mais ces deux gamins donc oui je vais
leur donner leur nom et le prénom ali
mansaré et puis salimi salle à nice ça
si pardon si l'ina diagouraga ce sont
des gamins qui sont intégrés ils
travaillent ils sont complètement
indépendants
le premier a pas on m'a dit il a rempli
sa fille sa déclaration d'impôts
hilarant piste stéphane il fait part
qu'il nous conte qu'elle a été quelle a
été sa réaction à l'oeil quand il a su
que faisait une grève de la faim
alors c'est un grand timide et
il montre pas grand chose mais y'a pas
besoin de contrôler pas besoin qu'on me
dise merci
si je ne fais pas pour qu'on me dise
merci il est dans quel état d'esprit une
erreur il est pensez vous qu'on se
posait la question sur la psychologie
des migrants quand ils repartent
est ce que quelqu'un il ya pensé mais il
a peur pour vous la nuit quand même pas
peur pour moi au plus haut niveau de
votre santé vous êtes à le jeu c'est ici
que je fais quelque chose pour lui et
qui a des milliers d'internautes qui
réagissent il connaît plus les réseaux
que moi moi je suis un vieux croûton là
dessus mais sanguine mou mais alors il y
voit que ça monte que et je voulais
aussi pardon je voulais remercier aussi
monsieur glucksmann bien sûr faire
réveiller cas très bien volleyé qui a
twitté j autres à voir si on pourra de
plus a explosé avant-hier j'ai lu france
bleu il m'a dit vous avez de signature
par seconde
c'est magnifique alors vous attendez
vous avez fait une pétition qui
s'adresse à girac darmanin et marlène
schiappa lui qui sont rattachés au
ministère de l'intérieur
est ce que vous voulez qu'on essaie
d'organiser peut-être une rencontre avec
l'un écoutez vous avez mon aval je
reviens quand vous et je voulais que
j'essaie d'appeler marine chapeau en
virée au coron mais bien sûr on va
essayer de voir et on va essayer de voir
si on va avoir un rendez vous avec
marine chabat j'espère qu'elle n'est pas
en lissage brésilien vous inquiétez pas
des noms mais et je pense qu'elle peut
être sensible à cette affaire est
peut-être regarder et au milieu bien on
va essayer c'est vrai que vous avez fait
une pétition qui a été relayée par
raphaël glucksmann et non la bouche
beaucoup raphaël qu'il s'en remit
dablain attention on appelle la ministre
déléguée par lynch a pas pour l'instant
4ème sonnerie heureusement que c'est pas
la valise rtl
alors j'espère qu'il ira mais si on me
rappelle je vais essayer voilà remonte à
paris c'est pas avoir un rendez vous
après vous connaissez le problème c'est
qu'ils vont dire comment on fait pour
tous les autres alors alors je lui ai
expliqué enfin bon c'est procès seule
province donner leur réponse
non mais moi aussi mais aussi vous savez
j'ai beaucoup réfléchi je le fais que ça
prend cependant minuit l'aïe
il lui manque six mois d'apprentissage
pour faire sens et ap je sais qu'il
l'aura je sais qu'il aura qui le passe
il faut qu ils le passent bien je suis
pourquoi donner autant d'argent à des
mineurs pour cassis a bien sûr à simon
lee long de générosité de la france pour
six mois exactement qu'est ce que ça
veut dire non il faut musique dont je ne
demande une sur rien kuhn 2006 six mois
non mais ça pour ça quand même pas rien
c'était pas pour les autres mais ils qui
confirme en france
il génère du bonheur dans leur
entreprise ils génèrent new le monsieur
sylla pleurer vous pensé parce que
c'était l'autre et à leur mode un bon à
rien maintenant au contraire
stéphane on va essayer de faire le
maximum ça chez nous pour vous et pour
l'oeil en tout cas je voudrais vous dire
chapeau pendant la petite chose et on a
écrit aujourd'hui à madame notre la fin
de notre président madame madame
brigitte et et on espère une réponse eh
ben on espère autant la réponse ils nous
regardent brigitte monde espère qu'il va
faire une réponse à stéphane stéphane
tout cas bravo pour votre émission
cerveau n'en finit plus j'espère que je
m'en fous l'avenir qu'on me remercie ses
parts tout cas moi vous c'est pourquoi
on a besoin de gens comme vous bravo
stéphane vraiment bravo continuez
boulangerie et s'il vous plaît vous
demande juste un truc
faites attention à votre santé mais
encore quelques kilos pas non mais bon
on veut fait attention
vraiment